time i was looked at like the biggest
[ __ ] ever you're an [ __ ] yeah
how'd the car get out of the car i got a
[ __ ] gun in this glove compartment
and i just would have gotta blow your
[ __ ] head up turns out our russian
soldiers all russian soldiers
we have reacted to hassan acting like
tommy
god so many people now i think it's time
to hear some tate stories all right
i love story i don't even need to give
them an introduction no you know
the [ __ ] man that's a very
opinionated man
teeth speech we're actually featured on
a tate speech overall what would you
give tate one to ten
[Music]
he was gonna get an eight he's down to
at least a seven really pretty cool yeah
first half of the story is actually all
on video as part of a web series i made
called the hateful tape which nobody
watched but i'm going to tell you the
very quick version of it if you want
more detail i recommend you watch the
video we're going to link it in here
anyway so me and my brother we decided a
long time ago that there's gonna be lots
of [ __ ] at the eurovision song contest
we came to this conclusion because lots
of people go there from all around the
world it's pop music it's [ __ ] we
thought there'd be some hoes so we
thought [ __ ] it one of these days we
have to go to eurovision last year it
was in kiev ukraine ukraine is some of
the hottest girls in the world so we
thought [ __ ] it we're gonna go to
eurovision this is the year to do it
we're gonna go to kiev we decided this
about two days before eurovision all the
flights into kiev were completely booked
it was extremely difficult to get to the
country so we thought how the [ __ ] we
gonna do this right now we're at
bucharest romania this is my house we've
got a map for about six hours from the
moldovan borders we thought [ __ ] it
we're gonna drive we jumped in the car
started driving you've never been to
eastern europe have you no i would love
to be i'd love to yeah i don't know
about i don't know about now right now
maybe later yeah it's hours to the
border of moldova and they wouldn't let
us through the border because
we didn't know at the time we need to
have the original paperwork to go into a
moldova because all the cars in europe
that are stolen end up in moldova so
they're very strict at the borders
unless you bribe them which i tried to
do and they wouldn't accept they didn't
know me
we can't there's no like way we can is
there a fine or we pay a fine or a
penalty
anything we can do it's not about the
penalty
it's about
that that'd be so nice if you could just
bribe yourself out of a lot of
situations like that used to be in the
old days it's harder now everything's
tracked yes
more sophistication you have that the
original paperwork we only had
photocopies of our paperwork we don't
keep the original paperwork in the car
so they wouldn't let us through so we
parked our car at a train station in a
town called the ash on the border of
romania we then went up to a taxi so
they could take us to kitchen now which
is the capital of the neighboring
country moldova it's effectively being
in france and saying continue to berlin
the capital of germany the long taxi
driver finally found a guy who would do
it
130.
for more money than we should have paid
he took us to cash now when we're in
kitchen now we had to negotiate a way to
kiev we found an overnight train and we
got there problem is on the overnight
train i nearly got robbed that train is
completely mafia run that train is you
can bribe your way in and out you don't
have to show a passport you don't have
to go through customs so all the russian
mafia who travel in and out of romania
and moldova
come in and out by train they do not go
by plane so that's a mafia run train and
that was very difficult and scary
experience up until this point all of
this is recorded and part of the hateful
tape series which we're gonna put link
to so feel free to watch it and find the
details immediately getting robbed
kissing out the train all that [ __ ] so
anyway the web series ends eurovision's
over me my brother in ukraine you gotta
get out so like how the [ __ ] we get out
all the planes are booked for another
week we don't want to stay in ukraine
for another week
we don't want to take the train again
because what happened the first time so
like well you can't fly you can't take a
train
you can't take a boat the only way is to
drive we gotta get a golf drive out here
somehow so we're going from taxi driver
to taxi driver thanks to everything can
you drive us to romania and it turns out
that ukrainians at the time which has
now changed i believe needed a visa to
get into romania so it's very difficult
for a taxi driver with a visa who was
prepared to do a [ __ ] 18-hour drive
i'll win
so we're sitting around ukraine for 12
hours every taxi driver i'm ordering
ubers i'm calling everyone up saying
look i need to get romania i'll pay
i mean it's
i was offering five six times the market
rate but i'm saying look i'm gonna give
you two grand remember these people make
250 300 a month i was offering them 2
000 us dollars for one drive so get me
the [ __ ] remaining i've got [ __ ] to
do i gotta get out of this country
eventually a guy we meet a guy who knows
a guy who knows a guy who knows a guy he
says i have a guy who has a visa
to go into romania and he's a very good
driver he's an ex-rally driver
and he's going to drive you and we're
like well thank [ __ ] let's go
so anyway me and my brother he said meet
us here at this time
so 11 o'clock at night me and my brother
standing on the street corner waiting
for [ __ ] mr no name to turn up in the
middle of kiev ukraine there's a
dangerous sea we're standing there
combat mode obviously chilling
the guy turns up now i expected like x
rally driver some kind of super g to
turn up some little [ __ ] some loser
turns up some dude that's been about
[ __ ] 17. hi i'm like hi who are you
because oh i'm your driver i thought
you're a rally driver it goes i was a
rally driver like when when you were 12.
what the [ __ ] this when do you drive
when you're 12. like whatever you got a
visa because yeah i got visa we're like
okay we trust you so anyway mr 12 year
old decides to drive us tristan goes
trista's nervous in cars my brother's
been in four car accidents none of which
he's been driving he's always been the
passenger in cars when cars have been
wrecked car accidents people have died
in like big car accidents but my brother
being a tate doesn't die easy so he's
very nervous in cars because i'm [ __ ]
i'm a bit nervous it's an 18 hour car
driving a [ __ ] 12 year old driving us
there's no street lights in ukraine
ukraine doesn't even have 3g you're such
a smart man that's a pretty [ __ ]
stupid situation to put yourself in well
yeah but
it happens i mean i've done some stupid
[ __ ] but that's like damn it's all
relative to the location i mean it's in
ukraine it's not that bad yeah this is
probably a little bit older too 2018 so
it wasn't as bad as it is now well yeah
there was an award going on but i think
there was um there wasn't well the
russian war i don't know if there was
some other [ __ ] but i don't think there
was i don't know let's go let's make it
[ __ ] up you have to have wi-fi even if
you have a ukrainian sim you can't check
facebook twitter nothing ukraine is much
poorer than romania i didn't expect that
romania is a poor country ukraine's a
[ __ ] poor country it's a war zone
it's a [ __ ] war anyway
so there's no street lights the roads
are bad trust has been nervous because
you know what ah this could be a
long-ass drive let's get a bottle of
vodka that's all right cool so we're
going to the store i remember this
because how cheap it was we've got two
snickers bars i bought a one liter of
vodka two uh cartons of cherry juice and
a pack of peanuts for two euros
including the vodka including a liter of
vodka two euros like how do you even
profit on that that's what i'm so
confused about a bottle of vodka alone
here is like 30 40
[ __ ] insane it's is the country that
poor
are our profit margins that large here
that it costs that little to produce
stuff or are they just like stealing
[ __ ] or making it so cheaply that's
pretty insane i have no way i know it
costs a lot more to
once stuff gets to the us border i mean
to transport it and store it and house
it and all that and and distribute it
then you get it it's something that's
made in the u.s it's it's cost more so i
don't know i don't know i don't know
what the hell i don't know i'm not an
international trader but you're right
that's crazy we get the car we should go
there we're sitting in the back of the
car drinking vodka we're driving down
these roads pitch black can't see [ __ ]
we don't know where we are our 3g isn't
loading on our phones so we can't see
where we are we're just sitting the back
drinking walking talking [ __ ] 3g
remember that huh remember 3g 3g we're
driving driving driving driving all of a
sudden the interest is we're this is
about six hours in liter vodka's gone
it's between me and two you've had half
a liter each or whatever we're a little
bit drunk i'll see how many drinks i am
i'm 11 drinks which means what means we
need a [ __ ] drink
we're chilling i see someone outside the
car
blacked out
head to toe black that's tristan you see
that but it's black out anyway
he's like what's that so who the [ __ ] is
this
we're driving down this bumpy road chris
has looked out the window and there's
another dude blacked i mean black
balaclava black ski mask black jumpsuit
black head to toes the [ __ ]
at this point me and him are drunk it's
two o'clock in the morning we're on the
border of ukraine we have no idea where
we're staring our windows we start
seeing all these guys dressed in
complete [ __ ] black i'm interested in
like this who said the wrong job where
are we he goes uh
ukraine we're like where in ukraine i
had a friend who once got robbed in
ukraine he got into the back of a taxi
and the taxi driver was driving the taxi
driver stopped two guys got in each side
of him while he was in the back both
with knives put the knives to him and
robbed him
so i thought okay so we're about to get
[ __ ] rod so i said to the rally
driver i said my friend you better
[ __ ] hope i get home it's like what i
said you better [ __ ] hope i get home
alive because i'm not the kind of guy
you want to [ __ ] with even if you kill
me you better hope i get home so i start
threatening the taxi driver i'm making
it clear i don't what would you do in
that situation exactly what he did
that's smart yes start threatening them
you got to threaten the [ __ ] guy you
just got to be the craziest person in
the room [ __ ] that yeah that's wild i
mean like we have to worry about getting
robbed here but it's way crazier in
europe like here it's lock your car
don't be an idiot don't wear two
headphones in at the same time remind me
to tell you about kenny sometime
well who's kenny all right so me and my
best friend were at uh the bon jovi
concert at great woods down in
foxborough and it's an amphitheater down
here then i don't know what it's called
now
comcast center or some [ __ ] anyway so
we're there and a little bit we meet uh
these guys this group of guys and one of
them is named kenny and
kenny's friends want to leave but you
know we're all drinking we're having a
great time where we're all best friends
right kenny will drive you home he's
like i don't live like 15 minutes from
here i'm like we got you kenny don't
worry so we get after the show we get in
the car with kenny and we're driving and
we're driving and we're driving and he's
like goes right up here he's right up
here and he told us it was 15 minutes
how far
now we're into like 45 minutes in and
i'm like i'm in the passenger seat
kenny's in the back and i won't give her
name she's driving and uh
we're driving down this country road
there's no lights there's nothing we're
just going to go and go and it was right
after college so i was 20 we were both
after the concert right yeah after the
concert and he keeps going just another
few minutes and i'm like i'm getting
driven to my death right now i'm
purposely driving to my death like this
guy and all his friends they're waiting
there and we're gonna we're gonna be in
for hell we're not taking kenny home so
i say you're [ __ ] with us kenny and i
know you're no i swear we're not listen
i'm not gonna go [ __ ] take you to all
your friends when we get raped and
murdered like not happen and he's like
no i'm sorry i was like i got a [ __ ]
gun in this glove compartment and i just
sort of kind of blow your [ __ ] head
off
no you did not oh i did i've never told
you this shirt and so
no no i said pull over and so i jump out
and i and i i pushed my seat forward it
was a two-door car and i get the [ __ ]
out of the car kenny and i throw him out
and he's like dude you can't leave me
here don't leave me here i go you
messing with us there's no noise or get
in the car which is super me get him
back in the car we drive about another
five minutes and my gut just went get
out of here so i said pull over again
pulled over threw him out of the car on
a dark country road and he's like please
don't leave and i was like and i got
back in the car i was like [ __ ] you
kenny and we [ __ ] took off we made a
u-turn and took off and i don't know if
kenny made it out of the woods a lot to
this day that was like 97. [ __ ] so you
went to a concert you met this guy and
he just asked you for a ride home yeah
well we were all hanging out like we met
them sitting in the room guys oh yeah
you did the right thing there no when
your gut starts telling you even when
you're drunk and you can hear your
intuition because your intuition is is
muted when you're drunk and i was
drinking you were literally driving down
a dark road i was in the passenger
how long like i'm going to say 45
minutes when he said he was 15 minutes
from the venue and every mile oh no it's
just just a couple more minutes just
couple more minutes no that's so up
yours kenny if you're watching kenny i
hope you had a bad [ __ ] night because
you creeped us out eat [ __ ] kenny get
[ __ ] if you ran into a bear he
probably just
sang a song he sang a song like excuse
me he's saying a bonjour [ __ ] hell
that's a that's a crazy story
if i died i thought he
should have known better this is ukraine
shit's about to go down i was in the
[ __ ] suburbs in massachusetts though
still should have known better [ __ ] can
happen anywhere tate holy [ __ ] i'm not
going to ukraine [ __ ] that all right
let's go turns out our russian soldiers
all russian soldiers i'm going to give
you all a quick geography lesson because
i didn't know any of this geography up
until this event you heard that american
guys are russian soldiers research
post now until the geography lesson when
ussr fell in the early 1990s moldova was
being established as a country uh
there's part of moldova that want to
remain pro-russian moldova's like half
romania half russia half people seek
remaining half people speak russian it
was all part of ussr meaning it bespoke
russian when the ussr fell the romanians
gained influence and all the russian
population were afraid that when the
country officially changes to a romanian
speaking government they're going to
steal all the money which is exactly
what they do eastern europe is [ __ ]
nuts some crazy [ __ ] going on there so
the russians want to remain part of
russia so civil war kicked off and to
this day even though this war was in
1992 there's an area of moldova called
transnistria which wants to be part of
russia which isn't part of russia like a
crimea breakaway micronation it's about
20 or 30 kilometers in length tiny
little dot on the map which i'd never
[ __ ] heard of up until this point
so me and my brother got the car russian
soldiers from head to toe blacked out
not just soldiers not like you imagine a
soldier like a green thing on a gun
special forces blacked out and the
reason they were there is because all
the crimea warship was just going down
at this time the crimea peninsula and
all this crap in fact i read it when i
was researching post that the eur
european union was concerned that the
next place russia would annex would be
transnistria because they had such a
pro-russian mindset so the russian
government has kept a military presence
there since 1992 and it was [ __ ]
loaded with russian soldiers
we just got the car with our hands up
they got guns pointed ass we're like
yeah what who the [ __ ] are you
like this is more than just a routine
robbery they even had our mr [ __ ]
rally driver at gunpoint they're all at
gunpoint
they take us arrest us macho sits down
this room
and they're like who firstly they start
talking some russians like my friend we
don't speak russian it was a good 10
minute conversation with them yelling at
us in russia and us saying we don't
speak russian until they finally agreed
to find someone who spoke english i
don't think they even believed we didn't
speak russian i think i wouldn't even
know what to do in this situation that's
that's actually terrifying because
there's like nothing you can do yeah
it'll be extra scary as a woman because
that could get rapey
yeah i feel like they're just yelling at
them in russian just to bug them out
more let's just keep yelling at these
[ __ ] in russia and they could
have been telling fairy tales in russian
and just yeah just no idea just no idea
we spoke russian before they finally
conceded left the room these two big
[ __ ] guys and got some other [ __ ]
huge dude to come and sit down with his
broken ass english he said what are you
doing here
i said what am i doing where i'm trying
to go back to romania so where did you
come from i said eurovision song contest
what the [ __ ] else now i probably a lot
of times people have looked at me like
i'm a [ __ ] in my life but the
biggest the most important event in my
life the time i was looked at like the
biggest [ __ ] ever was this russian
soldier looking at me and my brother
three o'clock in the morning in the
middle of a [ __ ] micro nation war
zone and i said i'd been there i'm there
because of the eurovision song
yeah i mean
you're an [ __ ] yeah
oh my god we're in the middle of a civil
war you [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] kids it's
the driver's spot there's bombs flying
and kids starving and i'm at the [ __ ]
song contest what else would i be doing
here wait cause ukraine's got the most
beautiful [ __ ]
that is why he went there yeah the
[ __ ] are bad what else am i doing
here it's like this guy's crazy biggest
idiot i've ever met or a brave
[ __ ] anyway by completely
terrible my brother and i were wearing
black we had black t-shirts on i had
black jeans he had black dragon balls he
said why are you dressed in black
i said i don't know man we just got a
taxi from train we're trying to go back
to romania he goes you're impersonating
soldiers it's three o'clock in the
morning you're pretending you come from
eurovision you're dressed in black what
are you doing here so they accused us of
being american spies
like we're not spies we just want to go
back to romania we're sitting at the
interview room they come in now let me
tell you one thing that did actually
cross my mind because i'm a combatant
individual that's why i do this what i
did for a living so it always crosses my
mind to fight it always goes to mind
thinking okay this situation is pretty
bad can i fight my way out of this
there's two guys in the room with me
both arms they're both big guys but i
could probably take them hand-to-hand
because it's close combat but once i get
out there's [ __ ] like 30 guys they
had attack dogs rottweilers the whole
[ __ ] laws there's no way i can fight
without this all i can do is try and
like go along with the [ __ ] process
they bring our suitcases out the car
they pour all our [ __ ] on the floor the
dogs start going through our suitcases
these guys start ruffling through our
stuff they search me and tristan they
take uh we had to take our t-shirt off
take our jeans off we're standing in our
[ __ ] underwear handcuffed
[ __ ] little booth i'm gonna try and
google and find a picture of the exact
spot so you can see it a little booth in
transit do you think that's the exact
spot that'd be pretty crazy
he would have said if it was but it's uh
it's i think it's probably a decent
representation i mean i don't know what
else i'd expect to spot like in that
area to look like it looks like about
right goddamn
the accused of the american spies with
american and british passports at three
o'clock in the morning we're in a
micronation breakaway i was desperate to
get on my phone the reason for this is i
just actually met donald trump jr about
a month or a month and a half before
this so i have him on whatsapp he's my
boy that's my he's my boy my my girl
who's the one in the car with me when we
toss candy to the curb she's got a
picture with oh yeah it's dtt junior too
yeah that's pretty funny pretty funny
it's high level if secretary of state
said john what's happened so i can just
get to my whatsapp and just send some
messages the russian they're going to
want to kill me i mean they're going to
keep me for a while this might go on a
few weeks let me just get on whatsapp
and speak to some important people and
try and get the [ __ ] out saying look
guys just give me my phone i've got a
guy in romania who can speak romanian
and russian and you can talk to him and
he'll explain to you that i'm not a spy
i'm just a [ __ ] idiot that's gotta be
one of the most important things is
having connections like that so if when
crazy [ __ ] goes down i just i got a guy
that's like the coolest [ __ ] when people
have tons of connections i have so i
have some pretty dope connections for
being an 18 year old like i have yeah
but you gotta you gotta not use those
connections unless it you save those
forever no yeah i mean but i do if [ __ ]
hits the fan i got some people okay
you know
just don't but don't operate your life
around that because i'm saying you can
only use those favors once no yeah i'm
just saying like for you know my
contacts are a little stacked they're
not they're they're not bad not terrible
but you know
idiot who went to a shitty song contest
and called the wrong taxi my taxi driver
mr [ __ ] decided to drive through a
[ __ ] war zone i didn't know i didn't
know this was still technically a war i
had no [ __ ] idea i look at the rally
guy was kept separate to me and t i kept
looking out the window and the rally guy
was still out on the gravel road so i
should have known not to trust a 12
twelve-year-old he's standing outside
with a gun point at his head [ __ ] wet
in his pants me and trista are sitting
there arrested in our underwear
handcuffs saying look we're not spies
without spies why are you dressed like
soldiers we're not surprised anyway
i sat and said to the guy said look let
me get my phone i'll make some phone
calls this will go away he says you're
not going to touch your phone for a very
long time i said my friend
so don't call me your friend so fine
i'm not a spy i'm an idiot
just take the money that's in my bag and
let me go
and this is what i love about corrupt
countries he didn't say yes or no he
spoke to turn to his friend and said
something in russia
they spoke in russian for a few seconds
and i can guess what he said he said
count how much money is in his bag they
went in my bag and they started going to
my bag looking for money and they went
through it and they fought about seven
thousand american dollars and they sat
there and he goes
i never instantly there was no
pretending that they weren't gonna do it
they found the seven thousand it was
actually quite nice of them because they
could have just took it and kept me to
be fair but i guess you know they were
men of honor he goes okay here's the
deal
i never want to see you again i was like
trust me my friend i guarantee
i can promise i promise you yeah
kenny i am not seeing your ass again
poor kenny i took the 7 000 they let us
put my clothes back on they loaded us
back in sexy with the dork
after this we'll call her and we'll just
ask her about kenny and you'll get and
she'll just giggle guaranteed if i go
hey i was just telling sunny about kenny
and she'll just giggle she'll just be
great she'll just know every now and
then kenny comes up so what's the moral
of this story the moral of the story is
quite it's quite a few morals one what's
what's the more what's the moral of the
story well my story is don't let kenny
in your car because don't let a kid no
it's stupid
don't be a dumb girl and let kenny in
your car and let him be ignorant and you
know have your have your guard up i have
your guard up my [ __ ] are crazy out
here let's see what this guy thinks who
knows what would have happened if you
stayed and went all the way there yeah
no i i'm telling you my gut was like get
this [ __ ] kenny out of this car now
it's like the fact that i i was able to
play the i have a gun card and i'll blow
your head off kenny and he got scared is
hilarious that is so nuts he could have
reached around and choked me out but he
didn't know it's pretty crazy how humans
definitely have a sixth sense about
stuff like that or even like if i'm
leaving the house and i have a weird
feeling that i forgot something i swear
to god every time i forgot something and
i go back i look around and there's
something i forgot it's the weirdest
thing something like that some shit's
about to go down it's like there's
something inside of us that you can feel
yeah there's there's no way it's not
because that can't there's too many cool
incidents but how did he not have any
sixth sense like he's he he was like
yeah this kid's a 12 year old it was a
sunday night in transylvania it was a
green light yes he was desperate he
needed to get home green light to get
[ __ ] buckled he wasn't in
transylvania
that's where she went
to history two don't take taxis from key
up to anywhere if you want to live don't
go to war zone stay out of that part of
the world this is the part of the world
that no one goes to i live in a part of
the world that basically no one goes to
and then i go a little bit further to
the area where literally nobody goes no
one speaks english
no big americans there i live here
because i make money here but really
it's a crazy part of the world the
reason i'm telling this story is because
me and my brother and i are due to go
back there in two days we tried this
[ __ ] guy a friend of ours invited us
he said
what
look we've got some work there we got
some business make some money on top of
that there's a mini skirt competition i
mean come on who doesn't want to go to a
mini skirt competition in a war zone
like what the [ __ ]
there's a whole bunch of beautiful last
women who can't escape mini skirt
competitions it's a crazy place no one
goes there nobody goes here i've been i
know i've given all of you a geography
lesson none of you have heard of this
place for sure and now you're all on
google like what the [ __ ] so anyway i'm
going there in two days time hopefully i
don't run into my friend the border
guard this time i've actually got a visa
i've been i've seen my boys in romania
i've got high level visa romanian visas
saying look he's diplomat he's allowed
to come blah blah blah so hopefully
they'll let me in and out with ease
but um subscribe because everything that
goes down while i'm there at a couple
days time is going to end up on the
youtube channel that's exclusive so you
have to be subscription otherwise you're
not going to get it subscribe for that
if you want any more details on this
amazing story like i said watch the
hateful tape series it's a pretty good
story yeah yeah it's a good story yeah
hope the viewers enjoyed you had a
pretty good story there too there's so
much stuff i haven't told you yet oh go
oh boy it'll come out on the youtube
channel because i don't know about that
one well like always i'm giving a
hundred dollars to someone who likes
subscribes and joins my discord the get
[ __ ] done university how i take over
social media i already conquered tick
tock this is only what maybe my fifth
video on youtube and i'm already at
multiple thousand subscribers yeah
i'm a [ __ ] wizard on algorithms so if
you wanna be over here dealing with his
ego you don't gotta worry if you wanna
learn how to conquer join my discord and
you'll be entered for a cash giveaway
right on
peace now go walk the dog peace
[Music]
last [ __ ] yeah